we've been talking about them as if
there were just numbers but you're like
who knows what they are if you've got
random values of a B and C but you
actually know what they are right if I
gave you this and it was something gross
you couldn't factorize right you're like
I can't think of a pair numbers that
does that and does this right what would
you do we already just mentioned it if
you can't factorize you would you would
either complete the square or use the
quadratic formula right can someone
recite for me
actually you know what not someone can
we all recite the quadratic formula
please it starts with her - me plus or
minus these K minus 4ac the
discriminators told me thank you okay we
got there okay very good
now before you write this down with me
right I am talking about alpha and
beaters two separate things write the
quadratic formula has baked within it
both of those separate things because
mathematicians are lazy right we don't
write two numbers we put them both into
one what's the one symbol in here that
tells me this stands for three numbers
not one number the plus or minus very
good it's like hey for one of them do
this and then for the other one do this
right but I want to think of them as two
separate objects so here's what we're
gonna do
let's call alpha that one right the
minus one and that makes beta the the
plus one right so let's just write that
down right okay this is brilliant right
I know it's gonna take a little bit to
write the first line but then it gets
very easy from there if I took these two
guys and I just added them up right what
would happen well let's just let's just
write it out and see I've got minus B
minus all of this stuff and then I am
I'm adding these zeros aren't I so I'm
gonna add it to this thing okay so there
we go now whenever I deal with algebra
because I'm lazy I'm always looking for
things that cancel right things that
cancel it you know to write them on the
next line right can anyone tell me any
big glaring thing that cancels out of
these two lines here go ahead the Ritz
right that thing on
the square-root you've got a - over here
and then you've got a bless you
you've got a plush over here right you
add a number yeah take away a number the
numbers gone that make sense
so therefore what are we get all that
gets left with is is this guy here -
beyond - eh
and then you've got the the
discriminates gone it's cancelled right
and then I'm adding minus B on to a
again what happens to this - to be on -
a way a second cancel cancel this is the
- be on a that you proved earlier you
see that right so we just verified it
that works now you think oh that's nice
it cancelled out when you added them
what happens if you multiply them can I
give you a second we know what alpha and
beta are can you go ahead not write down
the Sun but write down the product and
then can you prove can you verify that
so up to this part here right can you
verify that we do get this result that
we saw before I'll give you a minute to
do some of that on your own we got there
who waited through all their algebra
yeah a few hands okay thank you hands
down now I was really interested when I
send this to you there were two very
distinct responses in the room some of
you were like oh this is gonna be awful
right because it does look in fairness
like it's gonna be awful but a few
others of you I heard you say it said oh
no this is easy right there's a way to
unlock what's going on that doesn't make
this complicated can someone tell me
what was the piece of knowledge we used
to turn this into an from a messy
looking problem to an easy one anyone
tell me
Sadam difference of two squares thank
you I know it's messy right and what
you've got here is something take away
something up the top there right
multiply by something plus something we
have a factorization for that like we
would say P squared minus Q squared
that's the difference of two squares is
just like before something takeaway
something and something plus something
that's what we've got on the top there I
know it's very messy which is what makes
it a bit hard to see but now
les it's exactly this just for this
particular P and this particular Q so
let's have a go and see it all unfold my
difference of two squares should be the
first thing squared take away the second
thing squared what is the first thing on
both of these it's negative B right so
when you square negative B what do you
get just B squared great there's the
first part of difference of squares
since it's the difference of squares the
next thing you do is a minus sign and
then it's a the other thing squared now
the other thing happens to be a square
roots yeah oh sweet hardly have to think
at all right here is the other thing b
squared minus 4ac it did have a square
root over it right but then I squared it
so it doesn't have a square anymore
okay that's the numerators that was
actually the messy part I've got the
denominators as well when you multiply
two fractions what do you do with the
denominators you also multiply them to a
times 2a
4a squared very good right we're
multiplying not adding them okay all
right lazy mathematician right what can
I cancel off the top there the B
Squared's right the B squared B squared
minus B squared
so all that leaves you is careful with
the double negative 4ac very good on the
bottom for a squared and you're like
cancel cancel cancel cancel and there's
the C on a that we saw before be happy
with that to make sense